next question hey David you've done a
lot of critiques of the intellectual
dark web and you very often mention Sam
Harris when you're talking about anti
intellectualism are you calling Sam
Harris and anti intellectual because I
don't think he is one I'm glad to have
this opportunity to clarify this Sam
Harris is included as far as I know in
the intellectual dark web which consists
of I'm going off the top of my head here
and Pat you'll fact-check me Ben Shapiro
Jordan Peterson Dave Rubin the weinstein
brothers yes Joe Rogan Joe Rogan Sam
Harris Steven Pinker Michael Shermer
Michael Shermer yeah okay so their
intellectual dark web whatever
I don't consider sam harris to be a
pseudo intellectual i believe that sam
harris does meet the definition of a
public intellectual that doesn't mean I
have to agree with him on everything so
for example on race and IQ I continue to
be of the mindset that the differences
that we see among racial groups to the
extent that we've just defined them the
way we do right now for this analysis
are not a result inherently of being a
member of that racial group in other
words Ashkenazi Jews had long periods of
time where they weren't allowed to do
anything other than basically read stuff
and debate it on the other hand you had
a long period of time where American
blacks were not allowed to learn to read
why would it be that surprising if on an
IQ test meant to measure a very
particular type of understanding or
intelligence you can call it or whatever
you would have Ashkenazi Jews scoring
better than African Americans that
doesn't mean that the Ashkenazi Jews
score better because they're asking
Ozzie Jews imagine if for that same
period of time Jews were not allowed to
read and it was blacks who were hanging
around discussing the Talmud and
debating law and ethics do you still
think that you would see the same IQ
test results so I think on that I kind
of disagree with Sam Harris but I do
believe that he is not one of the
pseudo-intellectuals we've identified in
the intellectual dark web well it just
sounds to me like the intellectual dark
web is a very diverse group of people
you know everyone from Sam Harris on the
left to Ben Shapiro on the right and
Dave Rubin in the middle as a classical
liberal yes they are exactly in the
middle with no political biases
whatsoever they just evaluate every idea
on his merits on its merits rather and
engage in the battle of ideas no listen
so yeah I don't if I've misspoken or not
misspoken if I've been ambiguous in the
past sam harris i don't consider to be a
pseudo intellectual and my mentions of
him in stories about the intellectual
dark web are only in explaining to the
audience who are the supposed members of
the IDW but I do not think sam harris is
a pseudo intellectual that doesn't mean
i agree with him on everything